Suddenly it seems the entire country is
talking about the.
All right,
so I guess it's our turn as well.
For those of you who are tuned to the
Wacky wild underside of the Internet,
you know that the alt right has existed
for a couple of years now,
but it's only in the last few days that
the mainstream has started talking about
it.
Last week,
Hillary Clinton attack me all right,
and a big speech which lead to coverage
in every newspaper and online outlet
across the globe.
Hillary blamed Breitbart.com
for mainstreaming racism,
which she said was proven by trump's
embrace of the alt right.
CNN and Fox News both aired clips from
the Rubin report in which Milo
Yiannopoulos talked about the alt right,
explaining it as a counter culture
movement,
uniting disaffected conservatives with
mischievous Internet meme makers,
the usual pundant.
Suddenly we're all experts on the
alright even though they didn't know
what it was while it was growing right
before their eyes.
This whole time,
our outrage culture always need some new
outrage to be outraged about,
and once Hillary mentioned the alt right
by name,
it meant the movement had officially
arrived.
The Albright seems to take many
different forms depending on who you
talk to,
mainstream media and pretty much the
entire left brand,
the alt right as a white supremacists
movement,
rallying around Donald Trump.
Their members hate blacks.
They hate Jews,
they hate Hispanics,
and they want some sort of racially pure
country to stop white genocide.
Mainstream Republicans see the alt right
as a group of loud mouth defensive
racist who are tearing the conservative
movement apart by throwing away
traditional conservative ideals like
small government and replacing them with
a win at all costs.
Candidate other say the outright is a
grassroots movement born out of natural
pushback to are increasingly political
correct society.
I think if you mix some of those
explanations together,
you get what the all or I really is,
but you have to add one more thing.
The Internet,
the alt right,
whatever version of it you claimed to be
was created right here on the Internet
and as something created by the
Internet,
it is as amorphous as the Internet
itself.
What the alt right really is though is a
band of a meme,
posters,
Anamae avatars and twitter eggs vying
for attention from people in power.
They posted Nazi means racist pictures
and offensive tweets with the express
intent of getting powerful people to
react,
respond,
and thus amplify their message.
They are keyboard warriors and
professional trolls,
trying to get attention from the sold
out and corrupt media and political
elite that we have.
The real alright isn't about one
political ideology as much as it is a
loosely linked group of people using
tools of the Internet to upset the
establishment.
Ironically,
in some ways this wrangling and mocking
of the establishment is exactly what the
Bernie Revolution was supposed to be.
But while Hillary put Bernie's
revolution on ice,
she is now elevated the alright to
mainstream status by giving a big speech
about it.
The alright wants attention more than
anything and they trolled her into
giving them exactly what they want.
Let me back up here for a sec because I
don't want to gloss over that whole
white supremacist.
Hate the blacks hate the Jews.
Kick out the Hispanics thing.
This portion of the alt right absolutely
does exist.
I see it on twitter every single day.
You can pause this video right now and
find thousands of images including Nazi
imagery,
racist characatures of minorities,
and plenty more.
Do a quick search on twitter,
a scan on reddit or a look at four Chan
and you'll see some pretty nasty stuff.
I don't like it,
but you guys know my policy on free
speech and free expression,
so I choose to ignore these images and
ideas rather than amplify them.
The real question though is do these
truly hateful racist means in tweets
represent a real movement of hate or
they designed just to get attention?
I think it's some combination of both,
some true racist mixed with a bunch of
people who just want to mess with those.
Empower.
How many of each of them are there?
We have no idea.
What we do know though is that these
people will very little real world
power.
Dwight's premises exist.
Yeah.
The Black Jew and Hispanic haters exist.
Yeah,
they do too.
Some people want to keep immigrants out
because of racism.
Yes,
but the people who make up the right
aren't the ones with the power.
Instead,
they are the ones trying to upset the
people in power,
and as for Donald Trump,
he has blacks and Jews and Hispanics on
his campaign staff.
This doesn't mean there aren't racists
supporters of trump.
Of course there are just as they're a
racist supporters of Hillary and
everyone else to ever run for president
ever trumps blunt language which has
attacked almost every group out there
often blurring the line between being
politically incorrect and truly hateful
is just an extension of the tactics that
the alt right keyboard warriors are
doing on their own.
Personally,
I think that the regressive left is more
of a threat to our democracy than the
all right.
The regressive left with its tactics of
stifling debate and silencing critics
has gained mainstream traction in our
media and in our universities.
These regressive,
not progressive ideas have become all
too common on the left and they've
actually given birth to the natural
response,
the alt right.
I know this firsthand not only from the
emails that you guys send me,
but also from all the students at Ucla
who came up to me after my event with
Milo Yiannopoulos a couple months ago to
tell me that they're supporting trump
just because they can't take the culture
of fear around speech anymore.
The alt right with its trump frogs and
photoshop.
Pictures of sick Hillary is little more
than a bunch of guys in their basements
using outreach culture against itself.
Most of us are not part of the
regressive left or the alright.
This is precisely why we must talk about
ideas honestly and not let the extremes
on either side control the debate.
As I've said many times before,
trump's wall might not be sensible or
sound policy,
but a wall in and of itself is not
racist.
If we refused to have a conversation
about immigration without yelling racist
at everyone who disagrees with us,
then we'll leave the conversation to
anyone who comes up with an easy answer.
Trump's wall is the easy answer to a
complex immigration problem and it's one
of the reasons that the alt right loves
him.
The alt right is the organic result of a
politically correct society that refuses
to engage in ideas in an honest way.
That doesn't mean the alt right is
right.
It just means that they're here and to
demonize them without understanding them
doesn't stop them.
It actually strengthens them.
My guest this week is Scott.
Adam Scott is the creator of the
nationally syndicated comic strip,
Dilbert,
as well as a proponent of Donald Trump's
tactics.
I don't know if he considers himself
part of the alt right,
but I would consider him part of it as
someone who's using Internet culture to
spread his ideas during this insane
election cycle.
We're going to dive into his feelings
about Donald trump and much more.
We'll be all right.
Twitter Nazis make memes of us in Nazi
costumes.
After the interview,
you'll only know if we retweet them
ourselves.
My guest this week is an author and
creator of the legendary dilbert comic
strip,
Scott Adams.
Welcome to the Rubin report.
Thanks for having me.
I'm very excited to talk to you,
but before we get into anything,
you've also received the Rubin Award,
which is for outstanding cartoonists.
They spell it the other way though.
Coincidentally.
Yes.
Although it's not as prestigious as you
might think because they changed the
rules some years ago that you couldn't
win it more than once a and there aren't
that many cartoonists in the world,
so if you stay alive long enough,
you got a good shot at a Rubin Award,
then you're pretty much good to win one,
but you want it back.
That's silver 15 years ago or something.
Right.
You want it.
Which is amazing because I'm so young.
So there you go.
All right,
well,
I'm very excited to talk to you and
we're gonna.
We're gonna.
Definitely do the politics stuff and the
trump stuff and all that,
but first for the people that probably
know dilbert but don't know much about
you personally,
uh,
you have a sort of interesting
backstory.
What kind of led you to becoming a
cartoon and it's everything you used to
be a regular working man,
is that fair to say?
Yeah,
it was.
I worked in two big companies now
working in a big bank in a cubicle and
then I went to the phone and worked in
another
cubicle and I,
um,
I actually,
my,
both of my career has ended the same
way.
I keep forgetting I can say anything I
want on here.
You can say absolutely anything for
years.
There are things that I've sort of
censor it or played down in my
backstory,
but let's break you out of self
censorship right now.
I'll put it right down there.
Yeah.
Um,
my banking career ended when my boss
called me in her office and told me in
direct language as directly as I'm going
to tell you that she couldn't promote me
anytime in the future because I'm a
white male.
Wow.
And she said it wasn't discrimination
per se in the normal sense,
it was that the,
I guess the local newspaper had
discovered that there was no diversity
in senior management and in order to
reverse that,
since the pipeline wasn't as good as it
should've been in either,
they pretty much just had to stop
promoting people who look like me.
Wow.
So I said,
well,
how long is that going to last?
And she said something like,
well,
it took 200 years to get here.
So it might take awhile to reverse this.
I made up that part,
but that was implied.
Um,
so I put my resume together and I left,
went to Pacific Bell,
started working there.
I got,
got on the fast track.
I was identified as an up and comer who
was ready for management.
And one day my boss called me into his
office and he sat down and I had to tell
you this,
but the word has come down.
I can't promote white males.
Wow.
And it's,
it was the same reason it was the
newspaper had discovered that they too
had a problem with diversity as senior
management.
So that was the point that as I like to
say,
when you hear the story,
you say to yourself,
wow,
that must have been a really bad day for
you,
but turns out that the moment you
realized that your efforts and your
outcomes are not related,
it really frees up your schedule.
So suddenly I taed for hobbies.
I wasn't coming in so early,
I wasn't working so late.
I started looking for other things to
do.
Yeah,
the things that I could control my own
fate a little bit.
So one of the things I tried to do,
and it's one of the many things I've
tried to do both before and after
Gilbert,
was to get a comic strip published,
didn't know how to do that.
Um,
and you know,
how do you do that?
Like what's the,
what's the process for getting a comic
strip started?
This was pre internet.
You couldn't find out anything free
Internet.
Hard to believe that time existed.
It was the time.
But this is a true story.
It's a,
this is sort of the amazing luck part
that everybody has in their story.
At some point,
you know,
any successful person,
if you look at their story,
it's like I worked hard,
I worked harder,
I worked hard.
This really fricking lucky thing.
And then something good happened.
Yeah.
So in my context where lots of things
that didn't work out for me,
but I got real lucky this time and I
was,
I came home,
I was thinking to myself,
how do I become a cartoonist?
And I was flipping through the channels
on TV and it was a TV show on how to
become a cartoonist.
Well,
but I'd missed like 28 minutes of the
half hour,
right?
And I just figured out what that's what
that must have been about.
And I wrote down the name of the host
from the closing credits and I wrote him
a regular snail mail letter and I said,
how do you become a cartoonist?
And he answered two page letter,
said,
buy this book,
use these materials.
And he said,
whatever happens,
don't get discouraged because the real
tough industry and you know,
you'll get rejected a lot,
you know,
don't give up.
So I,
I said,
oh,
this was great.
I bought the book,
I got the materials and put together
some comics that were just single panel
comics,
send them off to the major magazines
they ever rejected.
You know,
I just thought,
well,
I tried,
right.
It's the best you can do is try.
So I put all my materials in the closet
and I forgot about it.
A year goes by and one day I walk out
into the post office or to the mailbox
and there's a letter there from this
same cartoonist who had sent me the
original advice,
his name is Jack Cassidy and if he's
watching this hijack,
um,
and he,
he said that he was cleaning his office
and he came across my letter that was in
the bottom of a pile and he said that he
was just writing to make sure that I
hadn't given up.
Wow.
And that was the only reason he wrote
and I had given up.
And so I thought,
well,
maybe he knows something.
I don't know,
maybe you see something that,
that even the,
the,
uh,
the magazines didn't see in my work.
So I decided to raise my sights to
become,
to try to become a syndicated cartoonist
and newspapers all over the world as
opposed to just trying to get at,
you know,
a comic in a magazine because I figured
if I got rejected at that,
it would feel like progress because
that'd be good.
Rejected at a higher level that would
feel good.
Um,
I sent out my samples and united media,
one of the big sin that gets called and
offered me a contract.
Yeah.
I mean that's really just a great story
of not just perseverance but also that
someone else that you didn't even know
really dragged you back in when you were
out and also that your,
your work before that,
you hit that dead end of,
you know,
you're not going any further here.
It happened to me because of your skin.
It's interesting the way you described
it,
you don't sound like you were,
you sound like you sort of understood
what they were doing even though each
node as against he wasn't working for
you.
Yeah.
I have two minds of that.
Right?
There's my social mind which says yes,
there was no diversity in two major
companies that that's not a longterm
sustainable situation in this kind of a
country,
so it had to be fixed and if you let it
get fixed in its natural course of
events,
it would take too long.
It just would be untenable.
And it is also true that when someone
who looks like me,
a white male in 1979 gets fired from a
job without doing bad job or in this
case to sort of encouraged to quit
again.
I had lots of opportunities so it wasn't
the worst thing in the world for me and
it worked out well obviously.
Yeah.
So yeah,
I have two minds about it.
I think it was good for society,
bad for me at that moment,
but it worked out good for me in the
long run.
Yeah.
What do you think in 2016,
if the same thing happened to sort of a
middle management white guy and they
were told that now,
uh,
do you think the reaction from the
average person would be the same?
Do you think a normal corporate
atmosphere?
Do you think they would say it in such
sorta.
I think everything ages certain times.
Right?
So the tool you need know you have to
adjust it for the time.
If it's,
you know,
if it's years ago and you've got to
slavery,
you need a civil war,
right?
You got to go for the biggest bluntness
weapon you can,
if it's the,
you know,
the seventies and you still don't have
good representation in top jobs.
You need something less blunt than a
civil war,
but far more blunt than doing nothing
and just hoping for things to change.
Yeah.
So I was in favor of a sort of a punch
in the nose,
sort of,
uh,
you know,
to try to get things kick started.
But now I think things have improved,
right?
Nothing's fixed.
You know,
we haven't ended racism.
We haven't ended sexism.
Right.
But there are pockets in which it really
isn't a problem.
Yeah.
There are pockets where it's probably a
huge problem,
but you can choose your pocket now.
So if you were somewhere where there's a
huge problem,
we do mostly have mobility.
You can quit that job.
You can find a place where you do have
an advantage,
you know?
Um,
I saw a picture today this running
around twitter of the Huffington Post
editorial board.
It's 100 percent of white women.
Oh yeah.
I've seen that before.
So if you're working for a company,
you're a writer,
you're a white woman,
you got discriminated against,
there is someplace you can go,
right.
We're probably something like the
opposite is going to happen.
Right?
So I'm not saying that's good or bad,
I'm just saying that in the world of
2016 you can leave where you are,
you have,
you know,
mobility of sorts.
Nobody has perfect mobility,
but you can't move.
Right?
So you can control your own fate and the
way that you couldn't in 1979.
Right.
And it's funny because if we're talking
about the same Huffington post picture,
it's a long table.
All the women and the woman who took the
picture is saying,
oh,
look at our diversity here.
She means diversity in that there's a
lot of women or something to that
effect.
Yeah.
And she's actually showing you that's
just,
it's different than just all white men,
but does that really diversity per se.
There was amazing bit of blindness that
someone could tweet that publicly and be
proud of it.
Now I think we're all happy that women
that have,
you know,
all the opportunities.
I have literally never met anybody who
thought differently about that topic.
So you believe women are equal before
the commenters start going out and I
know he hates women or something.
I believe in equal opportunity.
I think every individual is different,
but of course you have to have equal
access.
Equal opportunity.
Yeah.
Alright.
So let's jump forward.
So now you,
you get the cartoon out there and it
starts taking off how much of it was
rattling around all the ideas of
Dilbert,
which is very much takes place obviously
in the time of your life that you were
working in the corporate atmosphere.
How much of those ideas were rattling
around in you while you were doing it?
I mean,
was that just your creative outlet to
not go crazy in a corporate job?
Well,
it turns out that Dilbert was sort of
the sum of all my frustrations from my
corporate world and it gave me an outlet
for them.
I hadn't been thinking in terms of,
you know,
Gosh,
I got to make a comic about that until I
actually started working on,
um,
but it was,
it was a handy outlet by personality.
Um,
I'm excited by problems.
I'm excited by chaos.
If it can,
I swear you can swear away.
I told you no rules.
I wasn't getting a if things go to shit.
Yeah.
Suddenly I feel good because there's
always opportunity.
Right,
right.
Things are broken.
At the very least,
there's a job for somebody who fixes
broken stuff,
right?
So every time something that's broken,
I think,
ah,
there's a,
there's an opportunity here.
So I just love that situation.
That's probably a good segue to the
trump stuff,
but I want to do some other stuff
before,
before we quite get there.
So I was doing a little research and I
knew you were into hypnotism.
Well,
I haven't had to test.
You are a trained certified hypnotist.
Yeah.
How did that come to be?
A well,
the back story and that is that my
mother gave birth to my younger sister
while my mother was,
um,
hypnosis a while while she was
hypnotized.
My family doctor was a hypnotist.
Uh,
and we hope he is a medical doctor,
but I know he was at least after this.
Right?
Well,
you all came out,
right?
Yeah.
We all okay about.
And My mother,
my mother reports that she felt no pain
did not have any drugs during childbirth
and was awake the whole time.
And now this is an unusual situation.
So even even though,
well hypnotized person,
20 percent at tops could feel that kind
of extreme phenomena,
but the other 80 percent can be deeply
influenced.
And so when I heard that story,
I was pretty young when I heard it.
I thought,
what is the superpower and how can I get
that?
It was part of my process of trying to
accumulate skills that would layer well
on whatever,
whatever I was naturally good at.
And I thought,
well,
knowing how the human mind works now he
had an influence at knowing how to
hypnotize people has got to work
everywhere.
Right?
Where would that not be a good idea?
Uh,
so do you practice it some.
I mean,
do people come to you if someone say,
I have a smoking problem or uh,
you know,
I eat too much or something and you say,
well,
I want to be hit and Desi and how do you
use it?
Actually.
So I've sentenced,
broadened what I,
what I call it hypnosis to include
anything in the field of persuasion,
influence it could be advertising a,
you know,
in the,
in the dating realm,
you know,
Game Theory or whatever it's called.
Um,
so there,
there are a million forms of it,
but it's all,
it's all about how to influence people
in there in the irrational sense.
Right?
So you could be using some of the basics
of hypnotism right now,
but you're not putting.
So people think of hypnotism,
I like,
I'm waiting for you to pull out the Stop
Watch and put me to sleep.
But you're saying there's,
there's sort of skills and lessons you
learned in that,
that you can apply that you probably put
into Dilbert and that you certainly are
using on twitter and things like that.
So when I was learning hypnosis,
of course I was doing the,
you know,
putting people in so-called hypnosis
trances and uh,
doing things like having them remember
their past lives,
which by the way is not real.
The past life things that really.
Cause I know a couple of people reading
that journey of souls know that during
the sit bone,
but it's all about the past life
regression and that whole thing.
Again,
I can tell you,
I,
as practice,
I would run a little ad in the local rag
to say,
come in for $20.
I will hypnotize you,
wouldn't show you your past lives and
person after person came in and sure
enough under hypnosis they could
remember past lives.
But at the time I thought I was actually
open minded about it.
I was like,
well maybe.
I mean,
how do you rule it out?
But I'd have to do a few.
You realize that none of them have lives
that you haven't seen on television.
Like nobody said.
Yeah,
I was,
uh,
I was an Ethiopian,
you know,
something that you wouldn't know what,
how their life was.
Everybody was an Egyptian princess or a
viking or a cowboy.
I think the most exotic Wa was a French
surf,
you know,
and I'm thinking nobody's.
Oh,
and here's the other thing.
I had person after person come in and
not one of them was Chinese in a prior
life and do some math,
math.
Right,
right.
Man.
And there's a lot of China,
a lot of Chinese people.
Somebody was Chinese and her prayer
life.
And if,
if there were such things as prior life.
Right.
So what do you think that tells you
about the human psyche or the human
condition that people,
you'd put them under Gnosis,
which you believe is a good practice and
that ultimately there.
So you would say that that's.
Then their site subconscious.
That's just exercising itself.
It's just,
yeah,
it's combining with their ego to like
just make up stories.
It's not just their subconscious is the
fact that the hypnotist has implanted
the suggestion that they can retrieve
their past memory,
and so that's enough that they imagine
that they are having actual memories.
Yeah.
The main thing you learn to practice
hypnosis to be a hypnotist is you have
to understand that people are irrational
all the time about everything,
and if you don't understand that,
you can't even do it because none of it
would make sense for a rational person.
People aren't.
You know,
if you think people are affected by data
and facts and good arguments,
you can't even do hypnosis.
The whole thing just falls apart.
You wait.
You don't think everyone though is like
that,
right?
You think 100 percent of the world are
rational pretty much all the time.
The Times when you're not or trivial,
so you know if you're balancing your
checkbook or or,
or trying to decide which object is
heavier and how much you need to lift it
as probably a rational decision,
but those are trivial in terms of our
lives.
It's not going to affect the house you
live,
you decide to live in the job,
you take the person you marry.
It's not gonna Affect,
you know,
uh,
the way you,
even the way you dress most of the time.
It certainly won't affect your political
choices.
Right?
Right.
So you would say those choices are done
in an irrational manner for most people
buying a house.
I mean people spend a lot of time
figuring out what house to buy or what
career to go and do you think those are
done it through irrational.
We make our decisions about people and
things and the first few seconds and
then everything after that is a
rationalization.
I'll give you a perfect examples from my
life.
A few prior relationships ago,
we were looking for a house,
looked at a bunch of them.
We both did like him.
We drove up to the house.
We ended up buying sat in the car
without even going inside the house.
Looked at each other and laughed because
that was our house [inaudible].
That was it.
Yeah.
And I don't know why,
I just had a look at a feel,
but without even seeing the inside of
the house without knowing,
you know,
what we would pay or anything like that
we had decided in.
Sure enough we bought that house.
Yeah.
Likewise.
It didn't work out.
That was great.
Yeah.
And another relationship,
we're looking for a car,
you know,
with my ex wife,
looked at car after car.
We pulled into one dealer,
stood there and looked at the car and I
just laughed because I didn't know
anything about the guard,
didn't know the specs to know the
mileage.
It didn't know anything.
I just knew that was going to be our
car.
Sure enough.
Yeah.
So for the people that go to a good
Julian houses and inspect every inch or
that go to 27 car dealerships and all
that,
that's a,
it's sort of,
you would describe that.
That's just sort of a different way of
doing things.
You're sort of going to find a feeling
that's going to appear.
Right.
That's not saying that everybody's doing
that,
but I'm aware of.
But you're aware of it.
Certainly there are some,
some things that would eliminate a car
from your potential.
If you're looking for a truck,
you're not going to buy a prius.
Right?
So there's a little bit of common sense
in there,
but when you get down to those final
choices,
that's,
that's all.
Just how it feels.
Yeah.
Interesting.
All right.
Should we go to politics?
Sure.
This is where they want us.
This is where all the trump frogs that
are very excited that I'm talking to
you.
This is what they want.
Did they fast forward to this?
However they already put on twitter the
time.
Say Skip.
The first x amount is,
the good stuff is at blah,
blah,
blah.
He had a job.
Okay,
let's get to trump.
All right,
so let's,
let's talk about trump a little bit.
So my sense of your support of trump
have,
please correct me if I'm wrong,
is not that you love him or his policies
don't always support.
I don't want to go too far with that
word out there.
And you've said some interesting things
about your support of Hillary.
So,
uh,
yeah,
so correct me if I'm wrong,
that it's not that you're necessarily
supporting trump,
but you like the techniques or you at
least understand the techniques that
he's using to get his message across and
I think they're very much in line with
some of the techniques that you just
described to me.
Is that a fair estimation?
And I'll backtrack the word support if
put it in my,
uh,
my words.
Yeah.
And put the context straight here.
Um,
I don't think that anybody who was about
seven years old should get hired for a
job that requires great mental agility,
flexibility,
high energy,
and even staying alive,
which is very important to do the job of
a president if they keep saying he's
high energy,
be alive.
Right?
So,
so it's hard for me to get on board
either of those choices because really
320 million people in the United States
and the best we could get his two 70
year old racist or biggest,
you know,
depending on which side you're looking
at it.
Yeah,
we'll,
we'll get into that,
both Megan and secondly,
my political views that don't really
align closely with either one of them,
but that said,
what I noticed last year,
it was trump ahead a,
an influencing or influencers I'm
toolset.
Um,
he had the skills of the hypnotist and
the skills of persuasion that I
immediately said being fairly early on
last year and said that's not normal
while he's doing his technique that
people don't understand,
he's just a better persuader.
And so I'm a big fan of his persuasion
talents and I think people need to
understand that in context and maybe not
think of him as the crazy clown.
It was lots of times there's intention
there and there's a lot of strategy and
you know,
he's playing the long game and a lot of
ways.
Yeah.
So can you describe that part of it that
uh,
you know,
a lot of people will say,
well,
he's just nuts or he says anything and
it's just all crazy and all that.
But what you're saying really is that
there is a method to this madness.
He's not just walking up there every day
and saying crazy things with no plan
that there's an actual plan and it's
pulling some of the,
the,
the tools that
you're talking about.
Planning might be overstating it because
who knows you,
you know,
in this kind of context how far in
advanced they really can plan or how
much makes sense.
But definitely he is saying,
how can I control the most energy?
Alright,
so persuasion is about making somebody
focus on your thing until they think
it's important because the human brain
is so dumb that it thinks whatever it
pays attention to the most is the best
or the worst or the most important.
But anyway,
in their minds it's priority rises right
now,
as long as he doesn't make too many
things,
people think he's the worst.
The attention alone is a positive,
right?
It's basically the heart of it,
This,
that it's an attention game that he's
using and that's why it was so easy to
dispatch the secret toolbox.
Yeah.
But if he had to mention one thing to
sort of,
you know,
shining object and it would be
manipulating attention,
but he also manipulates attention away
from things he doesn't want.
So,
um,
I,
my best example is during the first
debate a year ago when trump was asked
about his comments about women in the
past,
now this was a trap that nobody can get
out of,
right?
You can't say there's nothing you can
say because now the media has made
people's attention on these bad things.
So just focusing on it makes them seem
higher priority.
What does trump say?
He goes,
only rosie o'donnell and suddenly all
the energy sucked out of the question
and went to this visual,
a person who is disliked,
at least by the base,
you know,
the Republicans could be counted on to
have an extreme reaction.
So it's a face whenever you can put a
face to something,
a personality and a visual.
All the energy just sucks into the room.
And that was the moment I got out of my
chair.
So I wait a minute,
this is not normal.
And then I watched to see if he could
repeat it and he kept doing it and doing
it.
And then by the time he was doing the,
the low energy thing,
I think I was the first person probably
in the country who said,
okay,
that's not a random insult.
That's the end of Bush is dead.
And there isn't as,
that is what I call linguistic kill
shots are not just insults.
That's what people thought.
The first part.
These are engineered,
right?
So look at low energy,
how engineered this is,
right?
He takes something that hasn't been used
before in the political realm.
You know,
it's not the usual thing you say in
politics.
So therefore you can imbue it with his
own meaning,
right?
It's his own thing.
Then he picks something that matches the
physicality of the person.
That's another big trick or something.
When you look at them and you say,
yeah,
that feels right.
Right.
Now here's the thing.
Before he said that,
before he reframed a Bush as being low
energy,
I think most people had the same
impression I did.
I looked at that guy and I said,
you know,
he looks like a calm,
seasoned executive.
He,
it looks like he would be unruffled and
even a nuclear war.
That's exactly the kind of executive I
was running my country.
And then Bush says low energy and every
time you look at it and after that you
go,
well,
it does look a little low energy and you
don't even know why that's bad.
And the edit fields,
so we're in a bad.
So now he's created.
Here's the second,
the,
the other,
the other part that's important.
He creates a trap for confirmation bias
so that everything that Bush does,
using his normal personality makes you
think,
oh yeah,
it just.
So his label reinforces over time.
Same with Lion Ted Cruz.
Ted Cruz unfortunately has a little bit
of a distrust,
full face,
kind of slimy.
Some people just have that face,
right?
Yeah.
And because he's a politician and he's
going to say things that aren't true,
like,
all right,
but he got the tag.
Your confirmation bias will go to
everything he says.
He's lying,
he's lying.
So is that really the genius of this
that he said Lion Ted Cruz,
and he calls her crooked hillary when
there's every evidence to believe that
someone could call him those things and
be just as truthful,
if not more truthful than he's being
right because he's taken every position
we can talk about some of the
immigration stuff,
but he's already scaling that back so
well while it's important to pick the
one that people are already sort of
prime to believe or there's something
about his physicality that would make
them easily believe that trump.
There's a lot of things you can say
about him,
but what a Clinton has finally jumped on
that was sort of late in the process
because she was fighting Bernie and that
was a different fight.
But at this point she is going with the,
the racist,
irrational,
racist thing.
Yeah.
And that too is an engineered killshot I
believe I'm reasonably certain that she
has professionals working for one in
particular that I've nicknamed Godzilla
Godzilla is my pet name for Robert
Cialdini who wrote the book influence,
um,
who would be considered that the monster
of persuasion,
if you are going to hire one person to
persuade the world.
This is the guy that's the guy.
And apparently he did consult on,
um,
Obama's campaign.
It would be,
it would be surprising if he had not
been asked at least,
but I don't have confirmation of that.
Um,
but I do know that Clinton went from
having no persuasion game at all,
talking about facts and their experience
and her policies and realizing that that
wasn't going to work.
And then she went full trump the summer
and said,
forget about all my facts and policies.
I mean,
she's not forgetting them,
but she's not emphasizing.
You want to be real scared of this Guy
Kevin here.
And here's the best part.
Trump was using fear as a persuasion
technique is fears the best thing you
can do,
right?
You scare people.
They have to,
they have to fix that first.
You fixed your fear first,
then you work at the other stuff.
So he said,
look at these,
these terrorists coming in.
Look at the criminal who's crossing the
border.
Look at the,
you know,
the economy falling apart.
Now whether or not any that's true
generates fear.
Fear is real good for persuasion.
That what did,
what did Clinton half facts affects her,
her experience,
that's nothing.
And then she ratcheted it up and said,
no,
the real fear is trump,
right?
Because trump is saying maybe you've got
a fear from terrorists,
but if you think about it,
what are the odds that a terrorist is
going to kill you?
Right?
Low.
So that fear is good fear it worked,
but it's not like a comprehensive fear
that gets everybody in.
Clinton said,
if trump gets in the office is going to
have his finger on the nuclear codes and
you're all dead and suddenly she got all
kinds of purchase and you know,
in and her poll numbers started rising.
She basically has a commercial outright
now saying exactly that.
So.
Right.
So do you think there was a calculated,
what does that say then I guess about
the Clinton campaign that pretty much
this all went down last week.
Like this all seems to have come to a
head last week with the big speech
calling him a racist,
linking him to all right.
And breitbart and we'll get into all
that.
Um,
do you think there was really a sit down
where they said,
man,
the technique he's using is really
working and we have to now shift you out
of policy and all that stuff?
Or,
or was it just,
it's sort of low hanging fruit to call
someone a racist.
They're doing it to each other now.
It's just,
Oh,
you're a racist.
It's become meaningless.
I think for the most part the word has
become sort of meaningless.
But do you think there was a real
calculated sit down,
like the technique he's using is
working.
We better start playing ball this way.
They're both doing what I call the AB
testing is a word from the technology
world where you're testing one technique
and then you measure how well it does
and then you test another and if that
works better,
you go with this one.
If this one works better,
you try yet another one to see if that's
even better until you get the best one.
There is no doubt that they found out
there are other attacks weren't working.
Um,
I think there was a wiki leaks saying
that they,
they thought attacking him on his
business acumen.
Was it working because people sort of
had it in their mind that,
that he was good at that stuff,
whether that's true or not.
Right.
So I'll show you some bankruptcies,
but they go,
but wait a minute.
He's still his buildings everywhere.
So whether it's true or not.
Yeah.
The trouble with the bankruptcy stories,
who's name is on 500 entities and,
you know,
yeah,
four of them didn't go well.
So that's actually more like a home run
than a failure,
you know,
in,
in an entrepreneurial sense.
Um,
so yeah,
I think that they tested until they
found that the racist thing is the one
that stuck and because of the way he
talks is unfiltered a method and the
policies that he's put out,
they attract confirmation bias.
Um,
for those watching who don't know what
confirmation bias is,
it's a well known mental phenomena where
if you think something's true,
you imagine every bit of evidence to
support that.
Whether it is not,
you'll see,
you'll see it that way.
Once you've decided by the way,
that's,
that's what the hypnotist learns.
The hypnotist learns that once you've
decided,
which is the irrational decision,
that,
that there is no such thing as data and,
and rational or logic just doesn't
exist.
That you basically will then just go
through life finding just the things
that validate what you have presupposed
way back.
And let me prove that beyond any doubt,
if ration,
rational thinking and logic existed,
there would only be one religion.
We would all just figured it out.
There would be mostly people all on one
side and these and these political
events,
not to every time it's about 50 slash
50.
Right.
What are the odds of that,
right?
Like,
or,
uh,
I asked the question once,
where do,
where do all the smart people come out
on this?
Like if you pulled only smart people,
well educated,
really well informed,
smart people,
would they all have the same opinion now
if there was anything to logic and data
and thinking is thinking we're a real
thing.
Like we,
you know,
we were really,
taking the right data and making the
right decisions.
People would mostly be on the same side
and these political questions,
you know,
even if it's 75,
25,
it would be overwhelmingly,
you know,
on one side,
but they're not.
So as someone that cares about thinking
and critical thought and being smart and
all of that stuff,
this has to be a little depressing for
you.
Right?
I mean,
as you already said,
the 70 year old part and all that.
And we've only selected just these two,
but just the general discourse has to be
kind of depressing,
right?
Absolutely not because remember,
since,
um,
since my twenties when I learned
hypnosis,
I've abandoned the idea that anyone is
rational,
including me.
So once you abandoned that,
the world becomes far less frustrating,
not more so.
Let's look at the world that the rest of
you are living in.
And I feel sorry for your bachelors
living,
living in this world because if you're
looking at the people who are on the
other side of a political debate and
you're saying,
why can't they see the logic,
the rational arguments that are so clear
to me?
And the answer is always the same.
You're an idiot.
But guess what they're thinking they are
too.
And you know,
they're having exactly the same thought
where their set of confirmation bias and
they're so sure that they're right.
Sure.
So basically you're saying you,
Scott Adams don't have any of the
answers,
right?
But you're just saying this is,
this is the game.
So we have to deal with it in that
reality.
While I have all the answers,
if you're talking about the political
stuff you've got all the way and we
haven't gotten to that yet.
Yeah.
Well let's get to.
Let's go.
You wait,
before we get to all the answers.
That will be a better thing to probably
end with all the answers to everything.
Maybe we'll wrap up the show.
I could end the show if we get all the
answers.
Yeah,
we'll,
we'll see.
Uh,
but I'm curious.
So the racist word,
we've talked about it a lot on this show
that one of my issues has been how the
left has used the words of bigotry and
racism and homophobia and all of these
things.
They've used them so much to smear their
opponents that these words have no
longer have any meaning.
Really?
Totally disagree.
Yeah.
Racist never loses its power even now
because my feeling was absolutely need
both were firing at each other and it
didn't feel like it took anymore.
Oh No,
it's taken.
It's taken big time.
Yeah.
If if you talk to the average Clinton
supporter about what they think of
trump,
and this is something I've not seen in
any other election,
you'll see the person who dislikes trump
physically shake.
Yeah.
I've seen people talk about them and
their handshake,
like there's a lot of people.
I mean this is not just a few.
Observation is common that people will
spit and yell and shake and that's
because the racist claim sticks.
It's not because they think his policies
aren't as good.
They prefer this approach has nothing to
do that they think is actually a racist.
They've literally been convinced,
and so that's that subset of Clinton
supporters.
My suspicion though is that the average
person
out there,
here's the word racist,
sees the way these things have been
overused and the way we label everybody
and goes it actually in a way,
especially if you take the trump
supporters,
every time you call them a racist,
it actually,
they like it because they feel like
you've lost the argument,
so that's the word you're throwing out
there.
There's confirmation bias in in
inaction.
Oh,
I guess that's the best example of
someone calls you something bad and you
go.
So the,
the trump supporters believe is that
they're not racist or you know,
it's not a problem.
And so they,
they imagined the world in which those
insults or ineffective,
but they are totally effective.
It's,
it's the strongest sauce you could
possibly put on this spaghetti.
Terrible analogy that was there.
Uh,
yeah.
So that's the reason Clinton's using it
and I'm sure they've tested everything
else and found out,
wow,
this is super,
but let me get back to the confirmation
bias.
So look at the charge and look at all of
the things that trump is accused of and
we'll just pick anyone and of the bunch.
Let's take the judge curial a thing
where he said that the judge couldn't be
bias because in,
um,
in trump's words he was Mexican.
Now you hear that.
And even to my ears,
that's like,
the judge would be biased.
That couldn't be biased.
Right,
right,
right.
Okay.
Um,
so even to my ears that's like,
oh,
that's like a little red flag there.
So you back it up.
If you talk to someone who was born in
this country and their parents came from
Mexico,
what do they call themselves while
they're Americans?
Obviously they call themselves
Americans,
but in casual conversation they'd say,
I'm Mexican.
Same Way.
If you're a Italian blood,
but you,
you're two generations away from Italy,
people still say,
yeah,
I'm Italian.
It's an understood.
You're also American.
It was.
We just have.
So he used me.
He used the language the way people use
language,
right?
So,
so far he's not a racist.
He just used the language,
lay people do.
But he went further.
He said that because of that,
you would be biased.
Now you know who's biased.
Every fucking person,
every person in the world is bias.
There's no such thing as the unbiased
person.
There's a reason that,
that jury's pick,
um,
that,
uh,
lawyers kick people off of Jerry's
because of their experience that is
biased.
There's a reason that a judge can recuse
himself or herself because they know
they're biased.
So to imagine that someone who has,
let's say a Mexican heritage and
presumably their relatives are Mexican,
maybe he has,
maybe he's visited Mexico,
I don't know if that's true,
but at the very least he's got a family
influence.
What is more influential on your
decision making than your family and how
you have to live with them for the rest
of your life?
Imagine this judge ruling inexplicably
favorably for trump and then attending
this next family reunion right now.
Remove Mexican.
It doesn't matter who it is.
If this guy is,
if this guy does something that's
unpopular with his family,
that's the problem.
That's the perfect for a human.
Forget that is a judge.
Forget deals,
heritage and human.
In that situation,
it was almost guaranteed to be biased.
Now the question is,
is a professional judge,
can he see past that?
That's his job,
right?
Of course,
But it's still smart for trump to put
that out there because he's persuading a
legal case and both,
both sides are trying to persuade as
hard as they can.
So trump is putting it out there and
says,
hey,
you know,
and he's also persuading the public in
advance.
If I get a bad judgment,
I'm going to say people in this
situation can be biased.
If I get a good judgment,
I'm happy I go away.
So as he's not doing it as subtly as you
just laid out saying,
well,
this guy might be biased in a calm way.
You calmly laid it out.
He,
he goes to the easier but that.
But you're saying that's the whole,
that's why he gets attached point.
Yeah.
He gets attention.
So it's the attention on it that makes
it powerful.
So if you were to pick this apart as the
legal strategy and pick the actual
words,
there actually isn't any racism.
There is a comment about somebody who
has a race in this case,
uh,
has a,
a cultural heritage is a better word,
but everybody is influenced by all
their,
all of their influences.
Family influences their job.
They worked at their pack,
their background,
all of that.
Right.
I suppose the inherent problem with it
in that case is that had the,
had this judge been white of Irish
descent or Italian descent or some other
European descent,
you acknowledged she would have certain
biases,
but trump would've never figured out a
way to bring up his ethnic background.
I'm going to.
Let me give you an example right back to
your.
Let's say trump is doing some business
in Scotland,
which he is.
Let's say the people in Scotland got
really mad at him and formed a partition
and the people in Scotland just hated
him.
Yeah,
I think they're doing this over that
golf course.
All right,
so let's say there was a,
a,
you know,
a second generation Scottish judge.
I think even trump has some Scottish
blood.
Yeah,
I think so.
So in that case,
if a Scottish judge who had Scottish,
uh,
parents was involved and he knew that
the Scottish parents living in Scotland
were really,
really mad at trump.
Yeah.
Would it be fair to say that the
Scottish judge who was really an
American citizen with Scottish
background,
um,
could be biased?
I think so.
I mean,
wouldn't you know reasonable?
Yeah.
So basically you're just.
All you're doing really is just peeling
back the.
You're showing the wizard behind the
curtain here,
so more than anything else,
right?
You're not.
You're not defending the specifics of
what he's doing.
Oh No.
This in this case,
what I'm doing is giving the listeners
an example of what confirmation bias
looks like.
When you heard the judge curial comment
out of context.
It does sound like a racist statement.
Once you put it in its proper context,
that goes away and that's how
confirmation bias looks.
It looks just like that.
Yeah.
Do you blame?
Why don't.
Since you have a lot of blame in
general,
but do you prescribe the symptom of
trump to just everything that has
transpired over the last 20 years just
are terrible media that doesn't
challenge politicians are discourse
that's crumbled to the point of just
yelling racism at everybody are
politicians who lie.
I don't think trump is any bigger,
bigger of a liar.
Then Hillary is.
I think she's probably a bigger liar.
Everything being equal,
but he lies in more of a,
in a more of a regular person way.
And that makes people freak out.
She lies in more of a policy,
like it just all led up to him in a way
it seems kind of obvious.
Well,
you know,
we don't live in a single variable
world,
so you needed everything to be the way
it is.
Plus trump and again,
the results you have,
you can't,
he can't remove one of the important
variables.
And there were lots of them.
But I think the key variable,
and this is what I've been saying,
is trump's skill,
his skill at persuasion,
that is the story.
I don't think you could take a non
trump,
put them in this same world in 2016 and
say the world is crazy in the media,
is this,
um,
I don't think you could drop Kanye West
into there yet,
although I've said he does have some
really high persuasion skills,
but he doesn't have some of the other
stuff.
Um,
so yeah,
I think trump's specific phenomenon.
Yeah.
So.
Alright.
So I don't sense full trump's support.
Correct?
Or is that what you're not,
you have support,
you know,
I would never,
I never support the use of support
in terms of.
And yet at the same time,
I think a lot of people think you're
like one of the biggest trump supporters
out there and it's really just because
you're talking about his technique.
Uh,
I'm an admirer of his technique.
Yeah.
I,
unlike many people,
I'm very amused by his humor and his
personality.
And by the way,
before we were filming,
you mentioned you have a New York
background as do I from upstate New
York.
And I haven't talked to too many New
York people about this.
I'm going to run this by you.
I went to Suny Binghamton badly.
That was another piece of my news.
Hartwick.
Is that right?
Oh my God,
we're practically neighbors.
There you go.
The wrong times.
Um,
what was I talking about?
Upstate New York?
Upstate New York.
So when trump talks in these ways that
offend the world,
I as a New Yorker say,
that's not offensive talk.
Let's just talk.
Yeah,
that's just how I talked.
One of the,
um,
one of the things I had to learn to
change when I moved to California is
that when I talked like New York people
talk upstate or city,
it's,
there's a bluntness that is offensive
and I had to really work on that.
Also,
there's an arrogance or a perceived
arrogance of New Yorkers because we talk
honestly about things we're good at.
We also talk honestly about the things
we're bad at,
but that Kinda gets lost California.
Right?
And I was like,
Oh,
you have a big ego.
No,
I said,
I'm good at these things.
I'm just like,
you just like everybody.
We're all good at something.
We're bad at something.
How was that?
How was that terrible?
But the things that New Yorkers do is
they say,
man,
I want to punch that guy.
He knows he needs a,
he needs two bullets in the back of the
head,
you know,
I'll give him two in the chest.
One on one of the head is just normal
New York talk.
Yeah.
But you see that and a context.
And by the way,
I think this is purely a trump mistake,
meaning that there's,
I don't think there's somebody telling
them,
wait,
this stuff doesn't sound the same.
And as soon as you leave the street,
as soon as you leave,
your state really doesn't sound the
same.
Yeah.
It's funny because I was just telling
you I was.
I visited New York for the last 10 days.
I got back yesterday and even though I
lived there my whole life,
one of the things that I really noticed
about being in New York City for for 10
days was the incredible,
you know,
racial mix and every,
every type of person on earth is in that
city,
on subways together.
We're not killing each other.
We're pretty much just ignoring each
other because everyone's going to live
their lives.
And I thought there's something actually
beautiful about that.
It doesn't matter ultimately if keep
these people privately hate each other
for racist reasons or anything,
but they're all out there living their
lives.
That's not to say there isn't any crime
or any bad racism or something like
that.
But I thought that was actually
inspiring about New York that we're told
we live in this society that's so frayed
and everything,
and yet our best city has everybody
and we're doing that.
I love that example.
And to that point,
um,
I'm going to steal something that I
heard Dr Laura say one,
so I'm kind of,
you know,
maybe modifying the words a little bit,
but I'll credit her for the thought and
the thought is that you are what you do.
You're not what you think because if we
were judged by our thoughts,
we would all be executed for,
you know,
you should be killed for just the things
you were thinking,
right?
Um,
that's coming.
Yeah.
You are what you do.
And more importantly,
you are what you do recently.
Because if I'm judged by my past,
I got some problems.
If you're judged by your past,
you've probably got some problems too.
We were all in their twenties.
Ones,
right?
It's all,
it's all bad stuff in the past.
Yeah.
The goal of life is to improve.
So if we're not,
if we're not improving,
we've got a problem,
right?
I think both Clinton and trump have
probably improved and I think that
judging them,
either one of them by something that
happened in say 10 or more years ago is
um,
is probably a bad bet because we're all
bad people 10 years ago compared to how
we are now because ideally we're all
getting better,
smarter,
right?
Better informed.
Well the hope is by the law,
but people do obviously,
but the other way too to
so when people are judging,
for example of trump for his,
let's say his,
his recent focus on African Americans
and say that's in his mind.
He's not thinking that.
I say,
you're on the wrong page.
What,
what,
what counts is what he's doing and what
he was doing before it wasn't as good
because he wasn't mentioning,
you know,
other groups in society and now he is.
So he's gone from less good too good if
doing the right thing doesn't count
anymore,
what the fuck.
So that,
that's really fascinating.
So when they,
when they take something like the
immigration thing where he said we're
going to kick them all out day one,
then he tempered it this past week and
then it sounds like he untempered it by
saying,
you know,
first our in office,
it's going to start or something.
Those are all crazy comments,
like we're not getting rid of everybody.
Then the temporary actually I thought it
sounded somewhat sane and then I'm going
to do it in the first hour.
Sounds completely insane at that point.
Is there.
That's not crazy at all.
No,
no.
I get it.
He's using the tools you're talking
about but is there.
So I understand that,
but is there anything that he could say,
do you think that would turn off his
people because he immigration was their
number one thing and he pretty much.
I mean even Ann Coulter was
acknowledging it.
Like he backed off that because he was
trying,
I think to become better,
to become a more legitimate candidate.
Yeah.
So he had to throw them under the bus.
Well,
people who believed it,
I would.
I would put it in these terms.
In hypnosis,
there's something called pacing and
leading.
Pacing is when you match your subject in
any way you match their breathing,
the way they talked,
the way their their posture,
because if you do that long enough,
people get comfortable with you and then
you can do what's called leading,
so then you then you can do something
different and then people will start
doing the thing that you're doing,
so you start by copying them until they
learn to copy you.
Subconsciously.
They're not doing it intentionally.
It's a.
it's a major.
It's one of the biggest components of
hypnosis is that idea.
What trump is doing is pacing and
leading the entire Republican Party.
What you think he's doing is that he's
gone in and his ideas are a little
different and somehow with his,
you know,
he's punched his way through the top.
That is not what he's doing.
He hollowed out the gop and he's wearing
it as a skin.
When he's done,
the Republican Party will never be the
same.
He has changed it and he has improved
it.
He got in front of,
he got onstage at the Republican
convention and did a full throated what
I thought was completely sincere
endorsement of doing more to help the
Lbgtq community.
Peter Teal spoke.
He meant it and what happened with all
the Republicans as soon as.
As soon as he did that,
you don't hear anybody complaining about
that,
right?
Yeah,
and not that they would have complained
necessarily,
but the Republican party changed.
Trump changed them and they can't go
back.
He,
he pays them until he led them and on
immigration.
He pays them.
He said what they needed to hear until
they said,
trump,
trump.
He's our guy.
I feel good with you.
Now he's in a position to lead the repo,
the democratic side.
There were already there.
You know,
they wanted something kinder and gentler
going by the wayside.
Why don't want this to be dealt with in
the most humane way.
That also makes sense from the country,
but he's,
it's a little bit like,
but slightly different than Nixon goes
to China.
You know,
Nixon was a hard ass about China.
So when he went there,
people believed him that he wasn't just
selling out,
he was still Nixon.
People believe that trump is still
trump,
and if he sold them that he had their
interests in mind,
which he totally did.
All right.
For his Republican base,
he said,
I hear you about this immigration.
I'm going to make it my top priority.
He paced them,
they trusted him,
they got into side.
Now trump and nobody else can soften
that position.
No one else is in that position because
of the way he did it.
But it looks to the public like it's a
flip flop.
It's the opposite.
It's,
it's,
I'm sure it was intentional from the
beginning.
Right.
So,
so you would say that,
you know,
I saw a lot of people that after Peter
Teal spoke and trump had that nice
moment actually where he said the thing
about lgbt Americans and he got a,
what I think was a pretty spontaneous
applause break from the crowd based
Republicans.
Right,
right.
Um,
you know,
I saw that a lot of people after that
we're saying we'll still look what's in
the party platform.
And there's still stuff that's not great
on marriage equality and other things,
but you would argue that's basically
irrelevant at this point because he's
the,
he's the head,
he's the leader and he's made the
acknowledgement so.
Well,
they're not done.
I mean there's,
you know,
everything's a work in progress,
right?
But,
uh,
I think trump's support of the lgbt Q,
I lose a bunch of ladders.
Community was both sincere and a higher
priority than the wedding cakes.
And guess what?
I think the wedding cakes will be okay.
And the weddings,
uh,
yeah,
I think the Republican Party will,
will catch up in that sense.
So is that the irony?
The ultimate irony of trump more than
anything else is that while these people
get shaky when you're talking to them
and angry and stammering and sweaty and
all that stuff,
that he actually became the Republican
nominee by basically being pro gay
marriage.
He's not going to try to flip gay
He's for gay people to live equally
basically.
And at the same time he's been running
an antiwar.
He certainly doesn't want a nation build
that's pretty obvious.
He wants people that were giving things
to,
to pay us all of that stuff.
So he actually sort of killed the Neo
con part of it and killed the Christian
conservatives,
like he slayed them both on the way.
So he,
he should've become the left's favorite
Republican in a bizarre way.
Um,
and maybe still.
Well,
I mean,
I'm still predicting that he'll win in a
landslide.
Uh,
I know the polls don't look like that
right now,
but they're tightening as we're talking.
How much of that do you think is just
that there's a certain fear of saying
you're for trump
so people don't fall properly?
Probably a lot of it.
Um,
I know a lot of people who say they're
a,
that they won't say out loud that they
support trump.
Uh,
because since I said that I support
Hillary Clinton for my personal safety.
Yeah.
I want to get to that because I live in
California
where that's kind of important.
Um,
uh,
I've heard from people who say the same
thing.
They say,
oh my God,
I can't say it at work.
I can't say it to my family who can't
say it to my friends.
How many there are is the great mystery,
but I don't think they're being picked
up and pulling necessarily.
Yeah.
What do you make of the alt right that
everybody's talking about right now?
Do you?
I don't think you consider yourself part
of it.
You're sort of a do not.
You're a.
you're a parcel to it or something like
that.
Right?
Like because they're,
they're getting two or something like
that.
Like they are getting,
I think.
I think some of the techniques that they
are doing of upsetting people in power
with memes,
you know you have so nobody in the
basement,
they send out a Nazi meme to somebody
important.
That person retweets it.
Thus you're showing that you're
upsetting them and you're changing the
game from your basement.
Like some of that seems like the stuff
that you're talking about.
Well first of all,
I disavowed the alternative as I see
what I've done here.
I said,
you spy,
you endorsed trump thing.
I'm putting you in a disavowed trump.
I disavow everybody's going to Hillary
Clinton because that's best for my
personal safety.
I don't even know what they all were.
The,
the,
the uh,
all right.
Even is it,
isn't it like a grab bag of
miscellaneous things that other people
don't like.
It was pretty much what I described at
the beginning of this is polite.
People don't like it.
It's him.
So I'm not sure how one can,
can love that movement,
but it's certainly is having an impact.
Yeah.
But it's using the techniques you're
talking about,
right?
Like they're doing a lot of the leads
stuff.
They're upsetting people.
Empower everybody's using the techniques
we're using better than,
than others.
Um,
and yes,
I would say that I've observed them
intentionally trying to use the power of
the tools of persuasion,
but both sides are doing that now.
Yeah.
I'm curious because you've become so big
on twitter and you have your base on
twitter that,
that absolutely loves you.
Do you ever find that they're leading
you?
Do you ever find that you were about to
tweet something and go,
ah,
this could,
this could upset them or they'll get
confused or,
or as someone that's,
that's a writer and that's able to get a
thought out in a six panel cartoon that
twitter has some drawbacks when you're
trying to really formulate a thought.
All communication has drawbacks.
And I definitely,
um,
I'm definitely informed by who is
reading my tweets to keep them in a zone
that makes sense for the followers.
But beyond that,
I'm a big proponent of free speech,
so I'm not gonna I'm not gonna mute
myself.
Totally.
Uh,
I have what I lovingly recall.
Fuck you money.
So I don't have a boss.
You don't need to.
I don't need to make other people happy.
If I have something that needs to be
said,
I can do that.
Yeah,
you don't have to tell me the number.
But when did you realize you had fuck
you money?
Um,
10 years ago probably.
All right,
so let's do a little bit on hillary
because we kind of danced around her a
bit.
Uh,
it's
sort of all,
it's all encompassing.
This,
the top trump,
you're sort of talking hillary already.
We're just stuck in this thing.
Um,
what do you make of her?
Do you think?
It seems just uninspiring to me and I
consider her as much of a liar as I
consider trump and we're just screwed.
How's that?
How's that for a lead?
I'll tell you at this point in the race
if you're going to vote for the one
who's not the liar,
good luck.
Good luck.
I think there was a,
there was a point early on in the race
where you could say trump is lying way
more than Clinton,
but I think that difference has been
erased and the reason is that lying
worked really,
really well.
And so Clinton is sort of,
as I said earlier,
dispense with the facts that.
And she's more about a user are racist
and misogynist.
And I don't think,
as I've said,
I think that's confirmation bias.
It's not fact,
but the race has almost entirely,
if you think about it,
it's.
I've never seen this before.
The race has gone from talking about
policies and things in the world to
almost entirely talking about this gray
lump of matter in each of their heads
like that,
you know,
is,
is Hillary's sick or lying or whatever
is trump,
you know,
a crazy,
racist,
misogynist or whatever,
but it's all about the gray thing in
their skull.
Like,
what about the world?
Right?
So was that the obvious outcome here?
In a weird way,
if you,
if you go back six months and you really
saw what was going to happen here,
and you look at Hillary and Bernie,
actually they were gonna take him down
no matter what.
And if you saw what trump was building,
which as you said,
you saw it a little earlier than most
people.
In a way,
this was the obvious.
We were going to get to this,
right?
No matter what,
probably the gravity was sucking us to
this place.
Yes.
The,
the only unknown was whether Hillary
would go as dark as she went.
By the way that were dark probably came
from Godzilla.
Um,
that's,
that's an engineered word.
That's the word that you don't hear in
politics,
which is designed to attract
confirmation bias.
Hey,
everything trump is doing is dark now
for people that missed the beginning of
that clip.
That's what.
What's the guy's name again?
Uh,
so that would be Robert Cialdini.
I'm just hypothesizing.
I don't have confirmation that he's
working on the Clinton campaign advising
her in the persuasion arts.
Yeah.
Um,
okay.
So let's put trump and Clinton aside for
a second and I want to finish up with
free speech because that's sort of in
the thrust of everything that I do here.
And I know it's something that's
obviously very important to you.
Um,
what do you make of the state of free
speech in America in 2016 as a,
as a creator,
as someone that puts thoughts out there
and you do poke funded a lot of our
societal nonsensical ways that we self
censor.
Yeah,
it's,
it's interesting in many ways the world
is going in the same direction in the
sense that there's more of everything.
I mean,
I think in the old days,
more of something less of something
else,
but now there are more places that you
speak with complete freedom,
you know,
online and then there are fewer places
that you could do the same thing in
corporate America or in other places.
So in some ways there's more freedom
than ever,
but in a whole lot of places in,
in troubling ways,
there's less than ever.
I'm a little on the fence about how much
of that is bad and how much of it is
good because I do think that words
matter.
And I think that,
uh,
there are places where civil
conversation is more important than say
in your mind,
right?
For freedom of speech is overrated in
some contexts,
but you certainly have to have it to
have an effective government and an
effective country.
Right.
So to that end,
do you say Asana,
bringing it back to trump,
but unfortunately here,
but I have to,
for the purposes of that,
do you think that once in office,
if he became president,
do you think he'd be able to have those
conversations in that sort of space
where he's not doing these all these
tricks but doing,
I suspect your,
these?
Yeah.
Well,
I think if you imagine a president
trump,
um,
I could see two things happening once
that everybody moderates,
once they get the job.
I remember back in my corporate days,
um,
you know,
one of my coworkers would get promoted
to an important level of responsibility
and their personality would just change
overnight.
It started getting serious and they
would stop joking around.
Certainly trump would be doing some of
that,
right?
So there would be some moderation just
because the job,
I imagine just imagine yourself,
you know,
you're,
no matter what you're thinking before
you walk into the Oval Office,
right?
You walk into the Oval Office,
you're in the White House,
all right?
There's no way that doesn't change.
It's real now.
It's real.
That's the biggest influence you could
have,
and in fact,
a Chilean even writes about this,
the influence of your physical
environment in his new book,
which I'll,
I'll plug for them.
Presuasion predestination will be the
biggest book about persuasion.
The world's ever seen.
It will be massive.
I got an early copy,
so I saw,
um,
yes,
so trouble moderate just because of the
physical,
you know,
power of the office,
but also he's also created in
everybody's mind and expectation that he
does things that other people don't.
So if you're,
let's say you know that the heads of
China or Russia and trump says,
you know,
a crazy thing that people don't normally
say,
they're not going to say,
oh my God,
here it comes to the nukes.
They're good.
They're going to say that's what he
does.
That's.
Yeah.
So we have to stop thinking that China's
a bunch of idiots.
They're going to misconstrue what's
happening over here.
It could not be more clear.
The trump says things.
Other people that would say.
So if he does more of it,
people are gonna say,
well,
there's more of it.
Right?
So basically they would just have to
learn how to readjust already have,
I mean I think that process is done,
you know,
you just have to see enough of him to
say,
okay,
he's talking like I'm going to say a new
and we get that.
Yeah.
Once you get the that that's his style,
you're okay with it.
Yeah.
I think it's interesting what you said
about how so in some ways it feels like
we have less free speech and in some
ways it feels like we have more because
people will now use the internet to do
this.
There's some,
I'm a little caught between feeling that
the Internet side of it is good and bad
because so many people are doing it at
that.
I feel like I'm buried.
They're exercising their right to free
speech,
but then it also comes with you say all
kinds of things that you would never say
in person.
I have no problem with what they say.
As I say all the time that the show,
I don't like the Nazi memes and showing
all these rays actual racist things
about black people or whatever.
I wouldn't stop them from doing it,
um,
but I guess,
but still you would say that's a net
good because at least there's the
outlet.
Yeah.
Um,
I would say that anonymity is essential
in a free society.
You got to be able to say some things
anonymously,
but I'd also say that the cure for all
the bad stuff is sunlight and the more
of the anonymous people say horrible
things,
the more of the sunlight starts to,
you know,
eroded.
So I think you have to let it out before
you can kill it.
Yeah.
So to that point,
would you,
if someone was tweeting you all day and
sending you awful Nazi memes or any of
this made my entire day.
I said my policy is I just ignore them.
Occasionally I mute them and on a very
rare occasion if they just won't stop,
then I'll block them.
Um,
but I never amplify them because I feel
like,
well,
if I don't really pretend that they're
here then unless they,
you know what I mean?
Like they're not outside with
pitchforks,
they're just doing it from the comfort
of their own computer.
Do you basically think that that's a
good policy and in this way because
otherwise I feel like we're just making
their ideas bigger if every time,
if I get outraged that they sent me
something upsetting and then I outrage
somebody else by retweeting it and then
it becomes this never ending thing.
I feel like I'm judging everyone
individually because every once in a
while they'll say something that links
to some data.
Yeah,
and now look at that and say that's data
that.
I mean I don't.
Maybe I don't like where their
implication or where it heads or or any
of that,
but data is data so those I tend to let
stay,
but if somebody just comes on and yelled
some racial stuff that I usually just
block them right away.
Yeah.
All right.
Final thought.
You've already predicted.
It's a.
you're predicting a trump landslide.
Do you want to give you some percentages
but you want to put yourself out there
that I said some from last year,
98 percent trump landslide and hasn't
changed.
What has changed is that he's had
terrible weeks and if that week was the
only thing that happened until the end,
of course he would lose,
but that never stays the same.
That weeks are going to be up and down.
I think there are some big shocks to
come.
I think that all the trump shocks are
baked in.
There's almost nothing you could hear
about unless it was totally out of left
field that would make any difference.
Right?
But there's a whole bunch of stuff you
could hear about Clinton.
Um,
especially since she has government
experience,
right?
That,
that makes them more vulnerable to a
shock because if he did it in the
context of the government,
it seems worse.
Um,
so that alone I think almost guarantees
a trump victory really.
So basically that wiki leaks could just
drop something because we know they're
holding something.
It doesn't even have to be wiki leaks
could be anything.
It could be anything A.
Well,
I've thoroughly enjoyed talking to you
and I'm glad we were able to talk about
some of this stuff without sort of the
craziness attached to it because it
doesn't it feel like it's just crazy all
the time.
Right?
Crazy in the most entertaining ways.
I have never had more fun year of my
life.
I got to say I wake up every happy
because the news is going to entertain
me and,
and,
and people are.
People are.
People are engaged.
Engagement,
the engagement.
Look,
look what people learned about their
government this year about how the
primaries work,
you know,
that they are rigged a little bit.
I mean just the level of human
engagement is off the chart and I would
go so far as to say that a president
trump would probably encourage more
direct public participation because it
just feels like he needs it.
Clinton,
which was because he just loves it.
He loves that.
Well,
I think Clinton would do her thing and
her lobbyists would writer write
legislation.
It'd be like always,
but if you saw president trump,
you'd think almost anything was
possible.
So you'd say,
I got an idea and people are already
sending me all these ideas for building
the border wall with a,
with a light rail train on the top and
businesses and casinos and,
you know,
making it,
uh,
you know,
economic zone,
good guy.
We're here,
we're hearing all this big thinking on
one side and I,
I feel like something's being unleashed
in a good way.
Like a creative thing and we hope it's
not the,
you know,
some kind of a race war.
Yeah.
Is Out World War three.
All right,
well for more Scott and,
uh,
the dilbert cartoon and his thoughts and
blog and all that,
you can check out blog.dilbert.com.
Thanks for watching.
And we will do it again next week.